I'm sure you've heard about the middle
class shrinking growing wealth
inequality housing unaffordability plus
retirement savings and accessible health
care and declining purchasing power
these have become the Hallmarks of the
rapidly disappearing middle class which
has shrunk by over 10 percent within the
past 50 years
that might not sound like a big number
but keep in mind that refers to over 30
million people not to mention many of
the people who are still part of the
middle class are just scraping by the
mainstream media usually attributes the
shift to capitalism of billionaires
inflation and politics and agreed
there's no arguing that these factors
have definitely played a role in the
growing wealth inequality but what if I
told you that there was an X Factor that
no one ever talks about
tech tech is often seen in the exact
opposite light as the great equalizer
it's what gives everyone access to the
same information knowledge and
opportunities but rarely do people look
at the other side of this equation take
a look at this graph for example it
portrays the rise of tech over the past
50 years now compared to the graph of
the shrinking middle class you'll see
that it's almost a perfect inverse
relationship of course correlation does
not imply causation but thinking more
about it this would make a whole lot of
sense on a micro scale Tech guests made
traditional jobs like being a teacher
police officer and firefighter
completely unviable as the cost of
living in many areas has adapted the
tech compensation
so is this really just a correlation or
is Tech the corporate that's been
secretly destroying the middle class for
decades
taking a look back the impact of tech on
economics can be traced all the way back
to the 1950s this was the beginning of
modern tech as we saw the formation of
these silicon wafer industry
at the time Tech was really quite a
foreign topic to the general public it
was just something that super smart
researchers at prestigious universities
messed with similar to Quantum Computing
today
there was really no commercial
applications for tech and as such there
was really no money in Tech either it
was all funded by meager government
grants and University budgets so the
industry was really just filled with a
bunch of people who were truly
passionate about tech but all of this
would change in 1957. eight PhD
graduates were conducting research under
Professor William Shockley would take
his research and start their own company
Fairchild semiconductor
this betrayal would lead to the rise of
the entire semiconductor industry as it
led to the creation of dozens of tech
companies including both Intel and AMD
this made Tech a relatively viable
business by the 1970s but it still
didn't have all that big of an impact on
the economy most people just viewed it
as a fad or as a niche industry a
perfect example showcasing this mindset
is Steve ballmer's parents if you're not
familiar with Steve Ballmer he was the
former CEO of Microsoft and is worth
over a hundred billion dollars but back
in the 1970s when he told his parents
that he was going to drop out of
Stanford to join Bill Gates his dad said
what the heck is software and his mom
said why would a person ever need a
computer
let's just say those statements aged
really well but you can't even blame
them as Tech was seen in the same light
as crypto is today some people swear by
it claiming that it's the future of
money finance and economic growth most
however wouldn't put much more than 10
bucks in Bitcoin but it wasn't long
until the people who bet on Tech early
would start seeing massive upside
starting with Steve Jobs in 1978 Steve
Jobs would make his first million at age
23. Bill Gates would follow just a few
years later in 1981 but while this was
impressive it didn't really mean all
that much virtually all of their net
worth was just on paper this however
would all change on December 12 1980.
this was the day that Apple went public
giving Steve Jobs a net worth of 217
million dollars this too was completely
on paper but as a public company the
legitimacy of his wealth and attack
wealth in general skyrocketed six years
later Bill Gates would take it to the
next level with his own IPO that gave
him a net worth of 350 million dollars
just one year after this Bill Gates
would not just to become a billionaire
but the world's youngest billionaire it
was official you could make serious
money off of tech but that was still
very much a niche portion of the economy
it was something that young nerds who
have nothing to lose like Bill or Steve
messed with everyone else though had
real jobs if you know what I mean
fortunately for them ignoring Tech
didn't really affect them all that much
but this would slowly start to change
with the 1990s
the 1990s was characterized by an
explosion in the number of tech
companies the general public still
hadn't bought into Tech but investors
had as such anyone and everyone could
get funding to go try their locket and
making it big in the tech world and many
did hundreds of successful tech
companies were started during this time
period propelling their Founders into
the billions but that's not really what
we're concerned about we care more about
the tech industry's impact on the middle
class and this was really the first
middle class generation that got
involved in Tech in the late 80s and
early 90s an unprecedented number of
people would start majoring in computer
science over 40 000 people were getting
CS degrees every single year creating a
new sector of the middle class
things didn't get too out of hand though
what tech companies did pay generously
in the grand scheme of things
compensation was still relatively modest
in 1995 for example the average
Microsoft employee was making just under
60k for perspective the median household
income in 1995 was 37 000. so Tech
households were making about 50 more but
nothing too crazy from time to time you
would hear about some tech employee
that's a friend of a friend that became
a millionaire thanks to stock
compensation but this was more of a
gamble than anything else especially
during the.com bubble when the vast
majority of internet companies went
under
speaking of the.com bubble the burst
would completely destroy the tech Spirit
annual CS grads would fall from a peak
of 60 000 per year back down to 40 000
as people feared that Tech was indeed
just a fad I couldn't imagine the old
folks back in the day telling their
unemployed CS children that they told
them so they should have just become an
engineer or a government employee while
they wouldn't have had the same earnings
potential they would have had far more
stability and peace of mind this was the
state of tech for much of the 2000s well
there were a few startups like Google
and Facebook that were making strides
the big tech industry had fallen and it
had fallen hard in fact many of these
Tech Giants would never recover Cisco
for example was at one point the world's
largest company but during the.com crash
it would fall at 80 percent which they
still haven't recovered from it was the
same thing with Intel and atnt and Xerox
and basically every other Tech Giant of
the era Microsoft was the only giant
that ended up recovering but it took
them 17 years and a fundamental shift to
do so it seemed like the attack
prognosis was pretty clear Tech was here
to stay sure but its days of exponential
growth were over looking forward it
seemed like Tech would have just become
another established industry like
Finance Healthcare or education people
would of course continue pursuing CS
degrees but it wasn't in the hopes of
becoming an overnight millionaire the
perspective was much more pragmatic Tech
simply paid more than most other
Industries and these big giants like
Cisco and Microsoft were much more
reliable than the startups of the 80s
and 90s this created a new upper middle
class the tech class that were just
slightly more well-off than the middle
class this divide however was about to
grow to Indescribable proportions
foreign
[Music]
has gone through the roof over the past
15 years Google's meeting compensation
currently stands at 295 000 comparing
this to Microsoft's average compensation
30 years ago we're talking about over a
5x difference and this disparity becomes
even larger when we compare it to
household income growth over the past 30
years median household income hasn't
even doubled while Tech compensation has
over quintupled but that's not even that
accurate because the average household
is just earning cash while Tech
households are earning Tech stock which
over the past 15 years has been 5 to 10
times more valuable than cash so a 300
000 compensation package from Google is
actually closer to earning 700 or 800
000 in cash somewhere else in other
words back in the 1990s tech people at
the top tech companies were earning 40
to 50 more than the middle class today
it tech people at the top tech companies
are earning 10 times more we should also
mention that the term top tech people
encompasses far more people back in 1995
Microsoft themselves only had 18 000
employees today Microsoft has 221 000
Google has 174 000 Apple has 164 000
Mata has 71 000 and those are just the
mega tech companies zooming out we're
talking about tens of millions of people
who are earning Leaps and Bounds more
than any other profession and I think
this graph really encapsulates exactly
what I'm talking about tech has
objectively eclipsed every other sector
by nearly 10x and that was as of 2015.
also I'm not just talking about people
who are directly employed by these tech
companies or even people who are working
in Tech specifically I'm talking about
people who leverage Tech versus people
who didn't Uber is just a regular old
taxi company but combined with the power
of tech they're worth nearly a hundred
billion Airbnb is just a regular old
rental company but combined with the
power of tech there are worth over 80
billion similarly law firms are earning
90 million for just a few months of work
for a tech company teachers are earning
Millions for teaching online instead of
at public schools and the top
influencers are worth hundreds of
millions if not billions and those are
just a few examples Tech has seeped into
every industry and every sector and the
wealthiest people of any industry and
any sector are the ones leveraging and
investing in Tech everyone else is
unfortunately stuck at 40 to 60k jobs
hoping for a three percent raise every
year when Tech was only one to five
percent of the population this wasn't
too big of a deal but as Tech has grown
to Encompass 20 30 40 of the population
and in some cities even the majority we
have started to see a massive wealth
divide and it's not caused by the top
one percent or low taxes or capitalism
or any of that it's actually just caused
by our peers who made it in Tech let me
explain
[Music]
foreign
popular to blame some sort of elite
class or BlackRock for the Pains of the
majority that's not really the case Jeff
bezo is spending 500 million on a yacht
isn't causing your groceries and rent to
Skyrocket do you know what is though the
people around you
when someone around you is willing to
pay more for groceries or houses or cars
or whatever it be prices are naturally
going to go up and the best example of
this is Austin Austin has always been
part of the tech scene as it's home to
Dell but over the past 10 years and
especially during the pandemic every
tech company you can think of has
expanded to Austin or has grown their
presence in Austin I mean just take a
look at the companies with the largest
office space in Austin number one is of
course Dell but then you have apple
Google IBM Oracle indeed and The Meta as
such Austin has seen an insane influx of
high-paid tech workers from California
and Seattle consequently the median
price of a house has nearly tripled rent
has gone up 13 annually groceries have
gone up 14 annually and basically
everything else has become far less
affordable I've lived in Austin for
nearly my whole life and over the past
few years I've seen it countless
neighborhoods pop up where literally
every single person and works a remote
Tech job and owns a Tesla and I'm quite
confident that these people are the
number one reason for skyrocketing
prices in such cities this isn't to say
that we should blame these people or
that it's their fault by any means
though like anyone else they're just
trying to create the best lives for
themselves with that being said though
it's very important that we understand
the modern economy for what it is it's
not a case of the top one percent versus
everyone else it's a case of people in
Tech and its running sectors versus
people who are not the modern economy
works for Tech and it sucks for everyone
else this has been a growing trend for
many decades but we're currently at an
extreme Crossroads where the options are
basically to join or die and this makes
sense because moving forward everything
will be Tech related and we're currently
going through the painful transition to
where Tech becomes the majority so in
the end I'd don't think the current
economic pain is due to money printing
or high inflation or bad politics or any
of that though they all play a role for
sure rather I believe the current
economic pain is a byproduct of the
world economy evolving into one where
Tech is not just a leading voice but the
dominant voice if you're already part of
the tech World you'll have a great time
if you're not though the future won't be
all that different from a tech dystopia
and that's what's really happening to
the middle class speaking of the modern
tech economy a lot of people are worried
that AI is going to take everyone's jobs
check out this video to hear why that
won't be the case but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one
[Music]